2021 será el año en el que por fin
después de años y años de agón llosa
espera tendremos la nueva temporada de
twitch así que para celebrar que el arco
de la guerra sangrienta de los mil años
por fin será llevado a la animación y
tal vez sus novelas hoy veremos una
lista de los mejores y más poderosos si
caes en un boliche esta serie es un
universo con muchísimas cosas
interesantes pero aún así usualmente
este tipo de listas se centran más en
los mejores bancas y eso es algo que
opaca el hecho de que algunas chicas son
geniales y están riquísimos - esté en
estas horribles así que hoy vamos a
darle el respeto que se merecen estos
cinco analizando los 10 más poderosos y
sus habilidades así que si quieren ver
más contenido relacionado a play ya
saben qué hacer
pero antes de comenzar quiero aclarar
dos cosas primero una gran alerta de
spoiler tanto del arco final de play
como de la novela que infirió world ya
que si no has visto el último arco del
manga o no has leído la novela es tu
decisión ver el vídeo o no ya que
contiene algunos spoilers y segundo
sobre decir que esta lista está basada
en mi criterio y opinión si no estás de
acuerdo con algo de lo mencionado en
este vídeo o tienes tu propia lista
siéntete libre de compartir tus
opiniones con todos en los comentarios
hay 35 y que estaban en mi lista pero al
final no lograron llegar a los 10
primeros aún así y no quiero dejarlos
fuera el vídeo así que los mencionara y
rápidamente como menciones honoríficas y
son rodrigo cuya cudeyo mi chica se
sumió bach y de su iphone y zangetsu y
chivo decidí dejar atrás estos tres
chicas ya que no son lo suficientemente
poderosos como los demás o simplemente
no sabemos casi nada de ellos como con
la nueva zangetsu que más allá de una
nueva técnica no sabemos su verdadero
potencial aún así son liberaciones
bastante poderosas y con grandiosas
habilidades dicho esto comencemos con
los demás
wa ves que es el nombre de la zanpakutoh
de ys urquía el actual teniente de la
tercera división esta chica y usualmente
pasa desapercibido porque no recibe
tanto tiempo en pantalla como otros o
simplemente porque se ve raro pero que
su extraña apariencia no te engañe ya
que tiene una habilidad que lo convierte
en un adversario bastante difícil la
habilidad especial de web es que es
doblar el peso de cualquier cosa con lo
que su chica y entra en contacto ya sea
animado o inanimado por ejemplo si eres
un poquito que quiera golpear una vez a
una espada que pesa dos kilogramos
dichas espadas pasaría inmediatamente a
pesar cuatro kilogramos siquiera la
golpea de nuevo ahora pesaría ocho
kilogramos y de esta manera y sólo puede
golpear la espada tantas veces como él
quiera hasta que dice aspa pese tanto
que ya no puede ser levantada por su
portador dejando una en esencia
desarmado y vulnerable esto también se
puede hacer con seres vivos ya que como
vimos en la serie con el arrancar
avirama sólo dos cortes de guaguas que
fueron necesarios para que su cuerpo
pesará tanto que ya no podía ni siquiera
moverse quedando a merced de kia
estabilidad es tan poderosa y efectiva
que incluso puede afectar al mismísimo
lille barro
estén reuters más poderosos así que no
es una habilidad que va a tomarse a la
ligera
del mundo
se embolsa cura el ciclo de vida q ya es
uno de los más bellos y poderosos en
toda la serie conocemos a curas
activados de hasta dos oído pues con su
liberación la espada de byakuya se
dividen en mil fragmentos estos pequeños
fragmentos reflejan la luz y toman una
apariencia similar a pétalos de cerezo
todos y cada uno de estos pétalos son
como pequeñas cuchillas ya que tiene el
mismo filo y fuerza que la espada
original así que si tenían problemas
lidiando con una espada
imagínate pelear contra mil vía cuya
puede usar estas mil espadas para varios
propósitos controlando otros fragmentos
con el movimiento de su empuñadura y
desde su entrenamiento en el palacio
real el adquirir un mayor entendimiento
de su propio poder dándole un mejor
manejo de sus habilidades pueden usar
hacen bolsa cura para atacar a distancia
para defenderse o incluso para atrapar
sus enemigos prácticamente puede usarlo
para casi cualquier cosa que pueda
imaginar la única habilidad desembolsa
cura es el hecho de que para no salir
herido por su misma técnica esta pose de
algo denominado área segura que es un
área de 85 centímetros alrededor de vía
cuya en la que dichas cuchillas no
pueden entrar evitando dañar a su
usuario así que sus oponentes pueden
tomar ventaja de esta zona segura de la
misma manera que lo hizo sutiss ima pero
como dije desde
en el palacio real su manejo de todas
sus técnicas es mucho mayor volviéndolo
aún más poderoso
[Música]
creo que sí
quizás a lo largo de toda la serie
demostró tener un chico bastante normal
nada único pero en la novela de ken free
your world se nos reveló que ese no era
su verdadero chico o más o menos quizá
aquí siempre había odiado sus facultades
pues ésta estaba especialmente dirigida
a matar según inzaghi casi ni
representaba la muerte ya quizá alguien
jamás le gustó la idea de tener que
matar a nadie era alguien que prefería
la salida pacífica antes del combate a
raíz de este hoyo y disgusto por mucho
tiempo quizá aquí no había sido capaz de
entender totalmente a su espada y este
malentendido estaba causando que su
chica estuviera incompleto pero durante
su enfrentamiento con gijón en la novela
quizá que logró entender completamente a
sus empaquetó entendió que casini
no sólo representaba la muerte como él
pensaba que asesina y representa el
ciclo de la vida y la muerte logrando
así su verdadero sí que su nombre es
igual
cassini visualmente es idéntico al que
siempre vimos pero obtener el poder
completo de kas ekin y xaki entendió que
era más que una simple arma y era algo
distinto a las semanas ya que el poder
de kas ekin y no se encuentran las
cuchillas como en el 90% de las demás
armas
su poder se encuentra en la cadena la
cadena que mantiene unida su ampa culto
sería ahora la fuente es poder ya que en
tanto su chica y está activado quizá a
quien no podrá morir
esa es la habilidad de cádiz y ni
suscita que sean inmediatamente
cualquier herida de yishai y por más
grave que sea no importa cuántas veces
lo ataques él no morirá incluso la
novela y con y partió a la mitad es aquí
pero las cadenas de esos para los narón
inmediatamente resultando sin un rasguño
este sí que se mantiene activo en tanto
quizá aquí tenga poder ya que se queda
sin energía su psique se desactivará y
podrá ser herido de nuevo así que eso
puede ser considerado una debilidad en
resumen el xiquet es isaac y no le da
ninguna habilidad ofensiva prometerá su
espada esté liberada él no morirá
no me
en el arco final de bliss después de
muchísimo tiempo por fin se revelaría el
nombre de la espada de quién patxi una
de las chicas más bestias mostrados
hasta la fecha nos hará así que la
verdad es algo complicada de tratar ya
que como la mayoría de cosas en el arco
final de bliss sucedió muy rápido y no
sabemos un [ __ ] de nozar así ya que
hacer uno de los chicos más recientes
fue vista por muy pocos capítulos y no
sabemos mucho de sus habilidades pero
con lo poco que se nos mostró es más que
suficiente por ahora para ser
considerada una de las espadas más
fuertes ya que en términos de fuerza
bruta y poder puro no ser así destaca
notablemente no sólo por ser
notoriamente grande sino porque tiene
una de las hazañas más increíbles
demostradas en la serie al destruir de
un solo golpe un meteorito que tenía el
poder suficiente como para destruir todo
el 7 y de no ser así esta vez más a
poquito más simple de todo clic no tiene
habilidades locas como lanzar rayos de
energía o crear ilusiones no los hará si
corta pero corta muy bien ya que la
gracia de no ser así radica en su poder
absoluto incomparable fuerza bruta y
enorme capacidad de destrucción siendo
en palabras del mismo que empaque
capaz de cortar absolutamente todo
y con la espada de la actual capitán
comandante es de las más difíciles de
explicar ya que tiene una de las
habilidades más útiles y versátiles pero
también complicadas la habilidad del
chica y de que ahora q le permite hacer
que los juegos infantiles se conviertan
en una realidad aplicando las reglas de
cada juego a una batalla a muerte esta
habilidad hace posible que su suite
tenga una infinidad de habilidades
siempre y cuando entrene lo suficiente
entre las habilidades o juegos más
destacados de cateo con su está cajón y
que le permite a su uso y controlar su
sombra y la de su oponente y ocultarse
en ella o usarla para atacar girón y que
permite asunción nombrar cualquier color
si él o su oponente no tienen ropa o
algo de ese color ya nombrado todos los
ataques que reciban van a causar un daño
mínimo pero si por el contrario él o su
oponente tienen ropa o algo de color
nombrado el daño de cada ataque que
reciban se verá aumentado drásticamente
daruma zhang a coronda que lo que hace
es que si un oponente está mirando a su
uso y para el momento en el que él
termine de decir la frase de algo más
anda coronda son suites desaparecer a la
vista de su enemigo y por atacarlos de
cual
lugar sin que el enemigo se dé cuenta yo
vi que en resumen hace que entre más
mentiras de gas un switch o su oponente
más dolor y sufrimiento tendrá en
general cada tanque o costo tiene un
gran repertorio de técnicas muy útiles
que en la mayoría de ocasiones
benefician en gran parte a kira q y como
mencioné siempre y cuando él siga
entrenando para seguir añadiendo cuantas
técnicas y juegos que él quiera a su
amplio repertorio haciéndola una de las
espadas más poderosas y con una
capacidad ilimitada además haciendo un
tipo tan inteligente y todos nuestra
tengan las batallas todos sus juegos se
convierten en algo capaz de acabar con
un enemigo en segundos pues tienes a uno
de los personajes más fuertes de toda la
serie con una de las espadas más rotas
que existen
y estos cruces
en the south end
en la novela de que en frío número 12 no
se introdujo a un nuevo villano que
sería uno de los personajes más macabros
y sádicos de toda la serie
toki nada su novia hero que posee una de
las afectados menos conocidas pero una
de las más poderosas estás para
pertenecer clan es una ya giro y no es
personal no tiene solo dueño personas
han facultado generacional que se va
agregando el líder del clan esta espada
tiene dos chicas uno falso llamado cut
en yokuk que tiene la habilidad de
reflejar cualquier ataque que reciba
pero nos centraremos en su verdadero
fica y su nombre es en rack y hotel y
tienen la habilidad de copiar las
habilidades de cualquier otra santa
culto aunque sólo puede copiar las
habilidades que haya visto en la novela
sea liberatori nada copiar los poderes
de varias espadas copio las habilidades
desembolsa cura yori maru se sumaba chi
y muchas otras e incluso copió los
poderes de río bien ya caíd equivocas
widgets teniendo además la habilidad de
usar varios de estos poderes al mismo
tiempo aunque usarlas de esta manera
disminuye su poder individual esta
espada tiene dos debilidades bastante
importantes la primera es que el poder
de cada habilidad copiada acción de la
energía de su portador es decir si
toquen nada copia las habilidades de esa
goma
dejan ataron sus poderes serán mucho más
fuertes ya que toxina es mucho más
fuerte y tiene mayor reacción que hannah
tarot pero si por ejemplo toquen nada
quiere copiar a río jean jacques a sus
poderes obviamente serán mucho menores a
los de la río línea k original ya que
toki nada es mucho más débil que
yamamoto y la segunda habilidad de
guerra que yo tengo es que esta espada
absorbe el alma de su portador mientras
esté activada y presencia mientras su
chica el verdadero está activado matará
lentamente a su usuario aún así con
todas estas debilidades que no son para
menos en ratio tien logra ser una de las
espadas más poderosas vistas en which
imagínate a pelear con toques y nada
mientras usa los poderes de cinco
espadas al tiempo
[Música]
o queréis irse
de igual manera en la novela de ken fire
jon world otro personaje nuevo se nos
fue presentado y con que aportaría una
espada muy distinta a las demás
su nombre es cómic y domo y dentro de
esta espada está sellado uno de los
geólogos más poderosos que jamás
existieron la historia de este hollow
data de hace muchísimo tiempo de una
época en la que los shinigamis ni
siquiera tenían espadas cuando la
sociedad de almas era una organización
joven en estos tiempos habían hollow que
ahora cualquier otro hollow o criatura
que se encontrara creciendo cada vez más
poderoso aún así éste hollow quería ser
más poderoso así que viajó a la sociedad
de almas con la intención de devorar al
rey de las almas siendo tan fuerte que
logró derrotar a casi toda la sociedad
de almas e incluso a un joven llama moto
pero cuando subió al palacio del rey del
escuadrón cero signos de anda con juegos
y fue finalmente derrotado por hb al
quitarle su nombre con switch simonyi
pero el poder de este juego era tan
grande que ni maya tuvo que sellar lo en
una espada a la que vichy le llamaría y
cometido muy esta espada pasaría mucho
tiempo escondida en el palacio de su
hasta que durante todo el caos que hubo
con la guerra contra los coincide toki
nada la robó
el autor guaje y koné y como que tiene
tres comandos de activación
el primero es órbita las estrellas que
permite gijón y libras tan solo un brazo
el hollow y usarlo para atacar el
segundo comando es marca el funeral que
libera totalmente al geólogo sellado
llegando a ser tan grande como ya mí en
su resurrección en este estado y cometió
nueve puede invocar tantos solos como él
quiera y rugir con tal fuerza que
solamente hechos rugidos causan tornados
que pueden destruir partes de la
sociedad de almas y finalmente su tercer
comando es eclosión a los caídos y
cometido móvil aquí el halo vuelve a ser
liberado pero esta vez de un tamaño
mucho menor siendo el tamaño de barragán
aproximadamente entre los tres comandos
que tiene este es el más poderoso en
este estado el hollow es más poderoso
que un vasto olor de y extremadamente
veloz capaz de realizar un sonido que
incluso asustó a nelia green joe por su
velocidad puede lanzar ceros por uno de
sus ojos y es en general tan poderoso
que él sólo fue capaz de pelear y herir
de gravedad ángel green joe y sally bell
pero con todo este enorme poder debía
tener una debilidad la debilidad de
cómic y domo de es que sólo puede ser
usada por cándida
al rey de las almas es decir híbridos
personas con sangre de distintas razas
siendo tal vez los únicos capaces de
portar la espada ichigo kim jong y gijón
y como dije es tal vez lo hacen pacto
más extraña de todo blitz pero también
es una de las espadas que más caos y
destrucción pueden causar
[Música]
todos sabemos que de por si el viejo
yamamoto es un gran personaje e
indiscutiblemente uno de los más
poderosos de todo play y su espada sólo
ayuda a reafirmar esto ya que es sin
duda una de las espadas más peligrosas y
poderosas virgin ya que es la espada
elemental de fuego más fuerte en
existencia con esta activa le permite
llamamos auto controlar a la perfección
llamas capaces de reducir a cenizas todo
lo que se cruce en su camino pudiendo
utilizarlas como proyectiles como
ataques cuerpo a cuerpo o incluso puede
usar sus llamas para encerrar a sus
enemigos en una presión de fuego de la
que ni siquiera aysén fue capaz de
escapar de manera muy similar había cuya
yamamoto puede usar su psique para
distintos propósitos para diferenciar
este dado que esta es una de las espadas
más antiguas de toda la serie llama moto
entrenado por cientos de años para hacer
que estas imparables llamas sean una
extensión de su cuerpo pudiendo manejar
a su antojo convirtiéndolo en el proceso
en una de las espadas más poderosas
jamás vistas con una capacidad
destructiva incomparable logrando en
conjunto hacer casi imparable a su
portador es decir su comando de
liberación es literalmente reduce toda
la creación a cenizas que esperabas
[Música]
en el arco final de tweets todos podemos
darnos cuenta de qué tipo de
transformaciones locas cubo quería
acabar la serie por lo alto y qué mejor
manera de hacerlo que creando
habilidades root y si más de las que
sólo es infeliz podría salir victorioso
una de estas habilidades es el chica y
de josué quería ser comienzo se nos
muestra que el tipo es ridículamente
poderoso y que tiene múltiples técnicas
interesantes con su espada aún estando
sellada con su chica de activado las
cosas se ponen aún más locas cuando jim
o'neill es activada la espada comienza a
generar una enorme cantidad de tinta y
absolutamente todo lo que está tienta
todo que perderá su nombre y por ende su
poder la otra habilidad de simonyi es la
habilidad de la oscuridad lo cual hace
que absolutamente todas las cosas en el
mundo que posean el color negro se
convierten en su propio poder con esta
habilidad y chivas puede realizar una
técnica llamada fut en times at su río
en donde y tuviera una tasa con algo de
la oscuridad que él ahora posee luego de
esto él procede a beberla y a recitar un
conjuro lo cual le permite crear un
enorme mausoleo hecho enteramente de esa
oscuridad esta técnica le quitará toda
la oscuridad que posee a su oponente
lo que incluye su carne sangre y huesos
dejando absolutamente nada su
destrucción es tan absoluta que una vez
su oponente haya sido afectado por esta
técnica jamás podrá volver a regenerarse
a resucitar o tan siquiera seguir
existiendo en cualquier plano de la
existencia es sin duda un chica y algo
confuso de entender pero si te enfrentas
con este tipo es casi imposible ganar no
importa si eres extremadamente fuerte o
tienes un arma muy poderosa si la tinta
de simonyi toca tu arma o incluso tu
cuerpo quedará sin ningún poder ni
fuerza y ahora si se logra se va a ver
la tinta y chivas tiene poder de toda la
oscuridad del mundo en su lado y puede
eliminar te de la existencia misma si lo
haces enojar en resumen un monstruo
mira qué o
joe casillas
sí creo que todos sabíamos quién iba a
estar en este puesto ay ese es sin duda
alguna uno de los personajes más fuertes
de toda la serie y eso es en gran parte
gracias a su espada yo casi get su es
decir vamos a ese solo le bastó su
física y para [ __ ] completamente algo
te y 13 dos veces la habilidad de
kyokawa jets es la hipnosis perfecta lo
cual edades en la capacidad de manipular
los cinco sentidos de sus enemigos de la
manera que él quiera es una habilidad
bastante simple pero en cuanto ves de lo
que estás para es capaz de hacer
entiendes el por qué es tan fuerte la
hipnosis perfecta le permiten crear
cualquier tipo de ilusiones a todos sus
enemigos pudiendo jugar con su
percepción de lo que es real y que no en
pocas palabras a ese puede controlarse y
destruirte en segundos inquietud si tan
siquiera lo hayas notado
esta espada curiosamente no tiene
habilidades muy llamativas visualmente
ni siquiera cambia de forma cuando es
activada y eso es lo que la hace tan
aterradora ya que nunca vas a darte
cuenta si estás bajo el control de a
diesel o no y ahora sí si lo haces no
podrás hacer nada ya que sus poderes de
hipnosis son tan fuertes con importa si
eres consciente
estás bajo una ilusión no podrás hacer
nada al respecto de hecho otra
característica que se nos mostró de
dicha habilidad es que al igual que como
pasó con 100 years va a ser la hipnosis
perfecta te afectará sin importar que
hayan pasado cientos de años desde que
viste su liberación claro que no todo
puede ser perfecto de otra manera la
espada sería demasiado fuerte pues las
padecen también tiene sus limitaciones
como por ejemplo el hecho de que sólo
serás afectado porque o casi gets o si
viste su liberación ya que si no la ves
cuando es liberada ya sea porque no
estás presente o porque el personaje
ciego como en el caso de todos en las
habilidades de la espada no te afectarán
además existe una manera de salir del
control de aysén que se puede lograr
tocando su espada las cuales son las
únicas de habilidades conocidas del
ciclo de aysén pero estas debilidades se
quedan cortas al ver de lo que es capaz
dio casvi gets siendo una habilidad tan
absoluta que no sólo fue capaz de
hacerle frente a todo algo te interese y
engañarlos
creo que los efectos de equivocas we get
supieron afectar el mismísimo juha lo
que lo llevaría a su inminente derrota
esta espada posee sin duda alguna el
cica y más poderoso de todo click ya que
sin importar cuánto luche contra ella
podría atravesar tu corazón sin que tú
te des
[Música]
llegamos al final de este conteo de lo
que a mi parecer son los 16 más fuertes
en todo play desde hace ya bastante
tiempo que quería dedicarle un vídeo a
blades pero no había tenido el tiempo
para hacerlo pero con el anuncio hace un
par de meses acerca del regreso del
anime no quería casarme con las ganas de
hablar de esta serie que tanto me gusta
así que si quieres ver más vídeos
relacionados con clichés bueno ya sabes
blige es una de mis series favoritas y
estoy ansioso por ver su nueva temporada
y quién sabe tal vez si esta nueva serie
tiene éxito tengamos nuevos proyectos de
play tú qué piensas por ahora te dejará
al final un par de vídeos para que les
eches un vistazo hasta la próxima
[Música]